all right welcome everybody to
session
four in this uh stoic sunday series
which we've been doing now for
about a month and a half concentrating
on the cardinal virtues we did one
uh sentence specifically about all of
the virtues and what they encompassed
and then we've been concentrating on
each of the four in turn
so this time having looked at wisdom and
justice already we're going to be
looking at another virtue that for some
people gets confused with like stoicism
as such and that is the
virtue of
courage which is a very important one
within
stoic philosophy but in some respects
not the
most important right if we look at what
the actual stoics have to say there's
kind of a priority to wisdom and justice
that's why we looked at them first but
courage plays a really important role
and we're going to talk about
the scope of courage which is a lot
wider
than a lot of other people make it out
to be
before we get started
i do want to say that
you know one reason for doing these
deep dives into virtues is to to help
people not fall into
traps that are out there you know
stoicism has become very popular there's
a lot of people who glommed on to it
without a lot of uh serious study or
practice of static attacks they're bad
guides they're they mislead you about
what stoicism is and we've actually got
a term in the whole modern stoic
movement for people who do it with
respect primarily to courage and tied in
with traditional gender roles and stuff
that we call bruises right from bro
ambrose or you know all these these guys
who are you know pretty afraid of women
uh and and you know need to like show
what tough guys they are all the time
that's not stoicism and that's not even
really courage as we're going to see
as the stoics understand it you know
this is how stoicism gets
reduced or or transmuted into silliness
about like repressing emotions and
taking cold showers and how much you
bench bro and
but also you can say
without people who are you know like
into that sort of thing
uh you know fearlessly telling the truth
well you know because i think many of
you remember that case of the guy who
tried to claim stoicism as the reason
why he was making disparaging and racist
remarks to his asian co-workers and then
went before a british judge if you don't
know about that case we could talk about
that a little bit later on it's but he
claimed that being stoic meant you know
standing up and saying what you think
no not really the case
and that's not courage either
i do also want to say something about
terminology and the texts that we're
going to be using and
referencing so in greek andrea is the
the term that is translated as courage
or we'll talk about other english
possible translations as well and it is
indeed the word it's coming from the
word for
male or man aneer right
but by the time that the stoics are you
know um
major on the scene even i would say a
little bit before them
it's kind of losing that that single
gender
status right because plato is telling us
already in the republic that women can
display
andreia and certainly epictetus teacher
mussonius rufus is saying men and women
can both display andrea courage to the
same extent in latin the term is going
to be fortitudo right which we
you know easily turn into the english
cognate and so we should talk about
english terms
fortitude
courage
bravery these are these are common ways
in english of translating these greek or
latin terms and as we're going to see
bravery isn't quite enough courage in in
the way that we usually talk about it
isn't quite enough to translate it
completely but you know it's it's the
best we're going to get
in english
and if we want to understand stoicism
we cannot afford to
not go to the primary text to the
classic texts
and as i've said at the start of all of
these i'm going to give you a little
rundown about you know who we can read
and who you can go to you can easily
find almost all of these online uh
available to you for free
there's a very selected few that you you
can't and you'd have to order them
so you know what do we have we have the
late roman thinkers seneca epictetus
supplemented by you know uh
musonius rufus marcus aurelius heracles
all of these are you know what we call
late stoic authors
and then we have these really two
important summaries of stoic doctrine
diogenes liertase and arius ditumus
and then another
really invaluable source that we
want to use is
marcus tullius cicero who himself was
not a stoic
but
was very sympathetic the stoics right in
tuscaloosa disputations if you've read
through those i forget whether it's in
book three or book four uh he says if i
was not a an academic i would be a stoic
so you know he he really incorporates a
lot and he transmits a lot to us
but where should we start let's think
about something that i've brought up in
previous sessions this famous passage by
seneca in letter 120 that gives kind of
a summary of what the virtues are about
he says the desires had to be reigned in
fear to be suppressed proper actions to
be arranged debts to be paid therefore
we included
temperance or self-restraint bravery
courage prudence and justice assigning
to each quality its special function
now second knows that courage is way way
wider in scope than just reigning in
fear but that is something that we
typically associate with courage isn't
it
and that's the you might say default
starting point in our contemporary
culture and also in a lot of ancient
virtue ethics you're going to find that
aristotle
really frames courage as primarily being
about dealing with fear and confidence
um and doing so you know he thinks the
paradigm is the soldier on the
battlefield the stoics are going to
extend it much further
so there's several key aspects that i
want to
highlight or bullet point at the
beginning
about what stoics take courage to to
consistent to include
one of these is you know
this aspect of bravery which is not just
framed in terms of like resisting fear
but
understanding having knowledge about
what really is
worth fearing what what is
genuinely
fearful then there's also this aspect of
courage as including endurance including
what's later on going to be patience
right already in the stoics that that
sub-virtue is is quite important
but it's not just passive it's
there's a
let's keep moving aspect to it
perseverance would be another way of
thinking about it so now we've got two
important aspects of courage
another that's absolutely central to
stoic writings on this
magnaminity or great solidness being
able to rise above
all the silly bs and even the important
bs and just you know to to have what
they call a lofty spirit or a lofty mind
and then the fourth
dealing with emotions but not just
fear
or
not just fear plus confidence
thoroughness in in greek
but other emotions as well
this is something
really quite interesting about the
stoics
they think that courage has to do with
a wide range of emotions and how we
how we handle them so
cicero um
you know sort of echoing seneca tells us
there's four virtues from which all
moral rectitude and moral duty
flow and you know he tells us that all
is all that's morally right arises from
one of four sources the four the source
that we're really interested in here
is what he calls the greatness and
strength of a noble spirit the
magnaminity side of it that's connected
with
courage
in
letter 85 seneca discusses courage and
he points out that the person who has
and exercises courage in many cases
won't feel fear why not
because they
have knowledge about what is you know
genuinely something we should be afraid
of or concerned with or
worried about or anxious about and in
many cases
you know we find out we're not supposed
to be or it doesn't make sense to be
worried about those sorts of things the
person who is courageous knows that what
appears to be dangerous or harmful to
many other people and perhaps even to a
previous version of their self
isn't actually so
and seneca um
you know expands this by saying
um
[Music]
courage is neither rash bravado
nor thrill seeking nor a love of danger
rather it's a knowledge
about how to distinguish between what is
bad and what is not
courage is very careful of its own
safety but it's also very well able to
endure things whose bad appearance is
false
cicero in on duties book one and his
long discussion of courage tells us we
must never be guilty of seeming cowardly
and craven in the latin term there
and timidique right in the face of
danger but we also must be aware of
exposing ourselves to danger needlessly
nothing can be more foolhardy than that
so you know if you know you're aristotle
you know that courage is one of the
paradigm virtues for him and he talks
about the the cowardly person who gives
into fear but at the other extreme
there's the rash or foolhardy person who
either doesn't feel fear when they
should feel fear or who jumps into
things uh kind of silly
uh you know imprudently
very often as aristotle points out
they're actually motivated by fear the
fear of looking scared you know and we
can think of all sorts of contemporary
applications of this you know i'll just
point one out when you hear in american
uh policing the endless line in court
cases i was in fear of my life and
that's why i shot this guy full of holes
that's actually cowardliness
right and it's it's a kind of a rashness
that's cowardliness but we can talk
about that more later on the point is
just as for aristotelians for stoics
courage is a kind of without them
calling it this
middle position but it's one that's
motivated just as it was for plato as we
saw like for example in the fado where
socrates talks about philosophical
courage and other people's not really
courage
it's it's involving a kind of knowledge
knowing what's actually good for us
what's actually bad for us and what only
appears so
now
in all of these sessions one of the
things that we've been doing
is breaking uh things down along the way
that the stoics have and then kind of
putting them together in a composite
picture
and one of the great sources for this is
diogenes laertes lives of the
philosophers
those of you have been here before have
heard me mention this many many times
diogenes is not himself a stoic he is
somebody who you know writes a history
of philosophy but he provides us with a
summary of stoic doctrine in book seven
in his life of zeno
and he tells us that you know the colon
what what is valuable
and beautiful in itself has four types
is similar to what you know cicero and
seneca were saying and what is
courageous andreion in greek is part of
that
and you know if a person has virtue they
can both figure out and do what they
ought to do here actually he uses the
term theoretical practice and poeticae
and the things that ought to be done
include what ought to be endured
hupo
menettea
it also includes what should be chosen
what should be
[Music]
you know distributed things like that
but
we
we want to think about um
what ought to be endured what ought to
be
worked through you could say is another
way of translating it
a little bit earlier in in uh
uh book nine or book seven he talks
about courage as being knowledge
episteme in greek
of what we ought to choose
in greek
and what we ought to be cautious of eu
la bayon in greek now i'm going to come
back to that term in another
minute because it's really important but
the third thing is what is neither
the the neutral thing right so we've got
what ought to be chosen
what ought to be
exercised caution or
you know we should look at it
suspiciously or however you want to put
it and then what's in the middle the
things that aren't either of these
courage if you want to have real courage
you need to have
you know a knowledge of those things now
why did i bring up
you la beon well because
that is going to turn out to be
one of the stoic good emotions
the stoics say that you you know most
fears are actually groundless
but you can fear
rationally i mean there are some things
that you ought to be
worried about including your own
character and whether you're going to
measure up or not with those things we
can exercise caution or ulabaia in in
greek the stoics think that that's
something very important
there's two other sub-virtues
that in that passage diogenes laertes
talks about there's magnanimity which
you've heard me mention now several
times already megalos suchia
which is also a knowledge but here he
says it's a knowledge or a disposition a
hexis which makes one superior to
anything that happens whether good or
bad is the translation in the english uh
translation of diogenesis but it's
actually better to call it
you know things that are
worth paying attention to and the things
that are trivial uh falun kai spu dion
in
in greek so that's one aspect right and
then there's endurance carteria in greek
knowledge or habit which suggests what
we are to hold fast to again we have
this uh word emeneteon um what we're
supposed to remain in
what isn't what we're not supposed to
worry about and hold fast to and what is
neither so you see that there's a
you know courage is not just a feeling
for the stoics there's a
whole set of cognitive components not
just to courage itself but also to its
sub-virtues diogenes will also talk
about two other things he breaks courage
down into
constancy um
there's an english translation for it
apolaraxia
which is kind of an interesting term uh
given that the the stoics use this term
tonos uh to talk about like the
we we call it the tone or the tenor of
substances and things and stuff like
that
and so
um
these are some important ways of
breaking
courage down
into its sub-virtues arius didymus
who wrote an epitome of stoic ethics
very easy to get your hands on right um
broke it down to five different
subcategories which overlapped to some
degree with what diagnosed layer base is
telling us
he talks about um
perseverance that's translated there
to criteria the same thing that we just
called endurance right
is knowledge ready to persist in and we
see that same turn um a medicatin what
what has been correctly decided so once
you've actually figured out what you
ought to stick with what you ought to
hold to what you ought to
resist to um
or resist against rather then you have
to have perseverance or you have to have
endurance this is something that you do
over and over and over again right you
just said well i'm persevere and you've
made your decision up once and for all
you have to keep on making that decision
then he talks about something that fits
in with the you know the more
like having confidence part intrepidness
is how you're translating it um
thoroughly tastes a great way of
translating this to be bravery i think
knowledge through which we know we shall
not encounter anything truly terrible
udemy de noi in in greek the the things
that we think are are scary turn out not
to be
all that scary it's knowledge through
which we know we can handle things right
that's what uh confidence or
bravery turns out to be
then we see once again
great-heartedness is how it's being
translated magnaminity megalopsuchia in
greek is a knowledge that acts and he
uses the the term for doing things there
above what occurs naturally in both
worthwhile and worthless or trivial
matters once again we see those terms of
spudiolase and follows being used so
that's uh also quite quite important as
well
um
stout heartedness
literally like having a good soul you
know that's that's kind of a cool term
knowledge belonging to a soul as it
shows itself
invincible or unconquerable um
a che tone literally unable to be
mastered or conquered
it shows itself as such because it knows
itself as such
then finally now this is a really really
important aspect of it i tell my
students that you can display courage by
actually
doing your study
and doing your homework and you know
resisting the temptation to say i've
done enough let's let and to tell
yourself let's keep on going with this
philoponia if you know um your your
ancient greek at all ponos means toil
trouble pain right it means like the
things that you don't want to do like
you know for me as a professor the thing
i dislike the most about um
teaching is grading right and i have to
make myself do it well that's a task
that is a work a labor that i'm doing so
philipponia is translated as
industriousness
knowledge about what
knowledge which is able to accomplish
what is proposed without
being prevented by the toil diapono in
in greek it's the the ponos is dealt
with and this is very active this is not
just enduring it right this is doing it
doing what is difficult for us getting
up and doing public speaking might
involve
intrepidness the confidence part you
know realizing that it's not going to be
the end of the world if you say
something dumb or you stutter or
anything like that but it also might
involve filiponia industriousness right
so these are some we've already covered
a wide range of stuff right you see
courage for the stoics includes an awful
lot
cicero adds something to this saying
that a soul that is courageous and great
will exhibit two additional
characteristics one of these is an
indifference or contempt we can
translate it uh despicantia in latin
towards external things or circumstances
and then the other thing is that the
person will seek out occasions
to do things that he says
are not only great and in the highest
degree useful
but also very arduous and fraught with
danger to life into many things that
make worth living so the person who's
genuinely courageous notice there's two
sides of this they will seek out right
we say that you know they're the person
when everybody's running away
they run towards it think about you know
a firefighter or a
you know paramedic or somebody like that
the building is collapsing these are the
people who go in and they're looking for
are there survivors that we need to get
out right away right
but the other thing that's really
important
he says they do actions that are not
only great and in the highest degree
useful so they're not doing stupid
things just to make themselves look cool
they're not seeking out danger just to
seek out danger again that's foolishness
or foolhardiness
when it comes to the emotion matter
there's a few things that i want to
point out and again here we
go back to cicero and the discussion of
courage in on duties book one
so
cicero says that courage is indeed about
dealing with fear
but it's also about other emotions
one of the other emotions that he thinks
is particularly problematic and needs
the curb of courage
is anger he spends a lot of discussion
on like not seeking revenge
keeping things within proper bounds you
know and this is where wisdom and
justice come in
courage can very quickly degenerate into
something that's not courage but
actually opposed to it when wisdom and
justice get left out
so
um there's that and then he also tells
us
we need to
deal with and this requires courage
excessive desire cupiditas
desire for you know say
um
having sex or
uh getting you know acquiring things or
you know eating as much as we want
courage has something to do with that
it's not just temperance
courage plays a role
excessive pleasure voloptas
courage should should help us to resist
that
and interestingly pain or grief agritudo
in latin that's also
something
that courage should bear upon so cicero
very clearly thinks of courage as
applying to quite a few
of the emotions epictetus also tells us
some really interesting stuff about this
and i highly advise you if you haven't
read epictetus discourses you know that
is problem that's my favorite stoic text
epictetus's discourses
and the the two chapters that i'm gonna
talk about here are both in book two one
is book two chapter two and one is book
two chapter five book two chapter two is
called on confidence and caution
um and the the title is actually
a little bit
more interesting it literally says
that
confidence than being confident you know
feeling bravery or something like that
and
being cautious
thai
it's a verb
are not in conflict with each other they
don't they're not they're not in
contradiction
um
opium says i read that chapter last
night so well that's good because that
it's very fresh in your mind and it's a
great chapter and it's something i think
that anybody who's interested in
stoicism needs to
you know think about and and probably
remind themselves of so he says there
caution seems to be in a manner contrary
to confidence and contraries are in no
way consistent so there's a problem
right that which seems to many to be a
paradox of the matter under
consideration in my opinion
is of this kind
if we asserted that we ought to employ
caution and confidence in the same
things then people would be right you
know we would be inconsistent here
and that really would be a problem
but he says
it's not the case
we shouldn't employ both confidence and
caution
sometimes in relation to the same thing
but in different aspects so here's a
good example
death death is one of the scariest
things around right not just our own
death but the death of other people oh
what am i going to do if this person
dies
and he says that we can have confidence
or courage or bravery
against death
but we can have caution
which is a kind of fear
rational fear
against our own fear of death
so you see how these things can be
um employed in in similar ways
we should have cautioned when it comes
to the stuff that we actually have
control over we so we don't screw it up
right we can be like yeah i don't know
if i'm actually going to measure up um i
need to employ caution in that we can
have courage or confidence towards the
things that are externals that we don't
actually have control over isn't that an
interesting way of thinking about things
in that other chapter
uh
which is the fifth chapter of the of the
second book he talks about magnanimity
um my god it's and it's uh not megalo
suitcase it's uh mogalla fronesis if i
remember right and care epi malaya
um
this is about this is that great chapter
about the use of externals and playing
the game socrates played the game right
and um he says it's difficult to mingle
and and to bring together these two
things the carefulness of the the person
who's affected by the matter and the
firmness of him who has no regard for it
but it is not impossible
if it were then happiness would be
impossible but it's not so
we have to figure out how to
balance these two things
that's part of courage for the stoics
mussonius rufus um has something really
quite interesting to say and this is
where we're going to wrap up and i'll
start taking some of these these
questions and comments this is in
lecture three where he's talking about
should women be educated in philosophy
and musonia says rufus is yeah of course
they should um because they should they
need to be virtuous and are just as
capable of being virtuous as men are and
so he says as for courage certainly it's
to be expected that the educated woman
meaning trained in in philosophy will be
more courageous than the uneducated one
and the one who studied philosophy than
the one who is not and she will not
therefore submit to anything shameful
because of fear of death or
unwillingness to face hardship and she
will not be intimidated by anyone
because he is of noble birth or powerful
or wealthy no not even if he be the
tyrant of her city
for in fact she has schooled herself to
be high-minded and to think of death as
not an evil and life not as a good and
likewise not to shun hardship and never
for a moment to seek ease and indolence
so it is such a woman is likely to be
energetic
strong to endure pain prepared to
nourish her children at her own breast
and to serve her husband with her own
hands and willing to do things which one
would consider no better than slaves
work now lest anyone think that he's you
know reaffirming traditional gender
roles
if you look at his uh chapter on
marriage
partners are supposed to be equal
they're you know the husband is also
supposed to be serving the wife they're
supposed to be friends and companions
with each other
in virtue which both of them equally
need
in lecture six he says virtue is not
simply theoretical knowledge but it's
practical application as well
and so you know you have to act you have
to train yourself to act according to
principles so a person who wants to
become good not only must become
familiar with the preset
virtue but must be earnest and zealous
in applying these principles and then he
says
how could we acquire courage if we had
merely learned that the things which
seemed dreadful to the average person or
not to be feared but had no experience
in these sorts of things right we have
to be doing things as well as like
learning things right it's not enough
just to have quotes written down that
you you know oh good you know
the stoics to find courage this way okay
now i know what to do you actually have
to practice it right
and so he goes on and he says um
the philosopher's body should be well
prepared for physical activity because
the virtues make use of this as a
necessary instrument for the affairs of
life there's two kinds of training one
which is appropriate for the soul alone
the other which is common to both soul
and body we use the training common to
both when we discipline ourselves to
cold heat thirst hunger meager rations
hard beds avoidance of pleasures and
patients under suffering
by these things and others like them the
body is strengthened and becomes capable
of enduring hardship sturdy and ready
for any task the soul
is strengthened too because it is
trained for what does he say
courage
by patience under hardship and
self-control by abstinence from
pleasures so this is you know uh
musonius
pretty hardcore teacher epictetus's
mentor for a while um giving you an idea
about what you know
what it takes to acquire courage it's
not something that we just have in us
you know that some people are courageous
other peoples aren't
this is something that we require
training in all the time so you see that
that for the stoics courage really
covers an awful lot and there's a lot of
moving parts to it so to speak and they
are as some of you have pointed out
interconnected with each other
the last thing i'll say
is that if you want to see a really
great
of a
role model as the courageous person
seneca's letter number 95 towards the
end he explicitly says
the best example of this is cato and he
and he goes down a list of things that
he thinks are so
important um in that
all right so mark is here
um
uh good to see you um
let's see what else we've got mark says
i like the word reckless
yeah i mean you know we we need to have
words to describe the
person who is not courageous but is a
sort of a facsimile of of courage right
and seneca talks about this in in some
of his letters you know how people can
appear to have a virtue but they don't
really have the virtue
we should always be careful in judging
from like one
situation and being like oh look at how
brave that person is unless we actually
can look at the pattern of their conduct
we don't know if they're really brave or
not or whether they're being driven by
by other things so mark um says
we should fear allowing ourselves to
become vicious right and that is so
going back to the epictetus thing that's
something we should have cautioned
towards and we should also have aversion
towards being vicious right it shouldn't
just be like we find out that we're
vicious the reaction shouldn't be
uh not a big deal right
that's the thing we really should get
worked up about
and mark says sometimes virtuous
practice requires courage to sustain
courage is needed to resist its
perversion now that's an interesting
point there isn't it
um yeah you need some measure of courage
in order to like build upon
uh and make your courage greater and to
resist the things that would take that
courage away from you the stoics don't
quite frame it like that
but i think that's that's quite correct
right
mark goes on and says it's part of the
interconnectedness you've been noting
justice requires courage to be upheld
yeah and in turn requires knowledge or
wisdom these these virtues are
interconnected with each other they're
not all the same right it would be a
mistake to take on the position that
some people do or like you know there's
only virtue and all these sub-virtues
don't matter we do want to get down to
the nitty-gritty about how these
different um
aspects do reinforce each other and feed
into each other very important uh sudden
quitting says something kind of similar
it's all connected like if you come from
a bad place in life that was hard to get
out of but you know it would be easy to
slip back into it which makes you afraid
so you have to find the courage to
persevere in doing the hard things to
stay in a good place instead of letting
yourself go the easy way very yeah very
good uh point right there
anybody who's facing difficulties
whether it's you know like i mentioned
public speaking right when you ask
people what is the your biggest fear
lots and lots of people will say public
speaking
and um
you know you can understand it right i
mean i used to have this terrible
recurring dream that i think some of you
know about because i've mentioned it in
other places when i first started
teaching i would be going into this big
lecture hall
and it was like you know 10 minutes
before class started and the students
are filing in and you know like the
go-getters are up towards the front and
i get to the podium and it's like a 200
people lecture hall and then i realize i
have no idea what class i'm teaching or
where we are in the class you know how
far along in the semester so i'm trying
to kind of [ __ ] my way through and
i'm you know saying general things
trying to get a read from the students
about where we are and i'm i'm i'm
afraid right i'm afraid that they're
going to find out that i'm a fraud right
this is impostor syndrome right and uh i
i go through an entire 50-minute class
period never saying anything of
substance just trying to figure out
where we are and the students won't give
me anything helpful right um public
speaking right and then there's other
things like you know if you have an
addiction
that can be very very scary
you realize that there's something
you know wrong with your motivational
structure and you know that you can't
just snap your finger and change
everything and you're afraid of like
sliding back into things or if you're
dealing with abuse right
particularly if you're stuck in
relationships what are they going to say
next am i going to lose it and you know
attack them am i am i going to if i say
something are they going to attack me
these are all things that do in fact
require that we take the imperfect
courage that we have
and try to do something with it and and
we don't always succeed you know this is
something else that's worth pointing out
um
we often are going to fail and then we
need courage to pick ourselves up out of
the dirt and
keep going
i mean people feel feel
people fear
failure
in part because
there's this like sense that if i fail
everything is lost right and
perseverance
is part of you know saying no everything
isn't lost um
as i fear i can still make something of
this right
sen says acting virtuous as a stoic in a
non-stoic world requires courage because
doing the right thing to the stoic
virtues is considered wrong by the
nonstock well sometimes considered wrong
sometimes considered right
it you can't make a complete blanket
statement about that
i mean but maybe they they think that
doing the just thing is is good because
it's expedient right they don't have the
right motivational structure or reason
behind it
and and yeah in many cases
doing what you ought to do
from a stoic perspective and really from
any virtue ethics perspective from an
aristotelian perspective from a platonus
perspective even an epicurean
perspective people are going to say oh
you're doing the wrong thing and that's
because they they themselves have got
things
wrong and they inhabit a culture that
constantly gives us things that are
wrong-headed um you will never live in a
stoic world
um you know it's interesting i answered
a quora question a while back
you know what what if everybody in the
world were stoics and i think i started
the answer by saying
never going to be anything you have to
worry about you know
but if if it were um you know things
there'd be a lot more social harmony and
stuff like that but that is never going
to happen the best you can ever get are
temporary communities in which people
are
pretty good you know
but
there's always the risk of things
breaking down right
michael says why did the stoics hold so
different views regarding women
practicing philosophy compared to the
peripatetics antiquity in general wasn't
the golden age of feminism yeah i mean
the second part is right the first part
it's not as if they have like absolutely
radically different views or something
like that it's a matter of degrees i
mean a lot of it has less to do with the
philosophy and much more to do with the
culture of the time i mean you can say a
similar thing about the i'm just reading
you know virginia woolf's um a room with
a view and she's making similar uh uh
points about um poetry in the 18th
century in england right so it's not as
if this is just a ancient philosophy
sort of thing i mean the aristotle says
some bone-headed things about women that
if he were around today he would take
back the contemporary aristotelian
tradition doesn't think anything
remotely like that and is in large part
led by women's scholars like martha
nussbaum and uh who's not actually you
know aristotelian as such but you know
definitely important in there and amelie
rorty and gisela striker and
nancy sherman you know uh you know we
could go on and on and on right
um
[Music]
so you know i mean the stoics are more
enlightened when it comes to gender
roles um it kind of varies mussonius
rufus probably more so than epictetus
who doesn't hesitate to call men
effeminate and insist that men should
have beards and stuff like that right
and you know we can look at that we can
say well just as with aristotle
this is kind of a quirky silly thing
that maybe we
we set aside right and we we take uh
what we need from it and that's you know
that's one of the good things about
modern stoicism um
mark says arent actually outright argues
courage is necessary to be a citizen and
participate in the public sphere or
polis
uh would you say this correlates with
what any of the stoics say yeah you need
courage in order to fulfill your roles
some of which are probably going to be
political i mean i mentioned
um
seneca in letter 95 is using cato as a
prime example of the courageous person
one of the things that cato does that
impresses seneca
is that
he resists uh for you know as long as he
can
uh the the demands of both caesar and
pompeii before finally deciding to fight
in the civil war against caesar on the
side of pompeii right
um so yeah you you definitely need
courage particularly if you're living in
ancient rome but also in our times right
to stand up for what's right
against all the misinformation that's
that's out there to hold people to
standards requires courage it's very
easy in contemporary politics to say oh
you know our guys are good and we're not
going to criticize them you know one of
the things that's missing a lot of times
in contemporary politics
consistency and consistency requires
courage
you know somebody else who highlights
the need for courage as an absolutely
central virtue aleister mcintyre right
there's three virtues in particular in
after virtue that are necessary for
maintaining
institutions
as anything good
justice courage and truthfulness you
know so yeah
uh drav what are my views on nietzsche's
views on stoicism
um i think they're kind of garbage um
it's funny people always bring oh you
know
this wonderful passage in beyond good
and evil oh you do stoics you
self-tyrannize you've got nature wrong
and
you read it and you're like nietzsche
you just have a different conception of
nature than the stoics do it's sort of
like saying i like apples you like
oranges i don't you know therefore
you're wrong
and if you look a little bit deeper into
beyond good and evil this is why it's
important to actually read whole texts
right
nietzsche thinks that everybody does
self tyrannizing not just the stoics
it's it's part of the uh having a will
that is a complex arrangement of a will
to power
you know um so i wouldn't i wouldn't
read too much into i mean
who cares if nietzsche criticizes the
stoics um
concerned with is the criticism a good
criticism right it's not it's not
automatically right because nietzsche
says it or anything
um san quedom points out seneca has his
conflicting parts about women as well
yeah i mean seneca was probably
less
um
we could say
less consistent when it came to gender
and the possibility of virtue than
musonius rufus is
xeno appears to have been pretty
um enlightened himself that way but we
don't have any of his texts so you know
we don't know what the the stoic you
know the republic written by zeno the
politea actually was we just have a few
um
uh not even excerpts but rather um
summaries of it right
all right mark says you began the talk
noting broicism and how a notion of
courage might be misappropriated to
sustain toxic masculinity can you say
more about how caution could be
cultivated to combat that yeah that's a
that's a great uh point and then
somewhat tied to that more on the
relationship between courage and anger
yeah so two two important things um
well let's start with the first one
right so
um
broomicism definitely i mean whether or
not some people are like oh i don't like
the term toxic masculinity it is
appropriate everyone knows some a-holes
who pretend to be men and are really
brittle little wimps who just happen to
have strong bodies and out of control
uh tempers and stuff like that right and
who are often like you know
later on
some sympathetic people buy them out of
their troubles
um and we also know like the jim bros
who take too many steroids and go into
roid rages and stuff like that we know
the people who are bitter miserable
um you know misogynist as well and all
that figures into that they would love
to think of themselves as courageous
when they're not really courageous and i
mean again you don't have to be a stoic
in order to identify this the
aristotelian tradition is super clear on
this in aristotle and in later writers
um the platonus tradition also talks
about this right
even the epicurean tradition is going to
talk about this a little bit mostly in
the relation to to anger which we'll
talk about in a minute
so you know it's it's interesting to see
how easily
the egos of these broix are bruised and
then they feel like they have to
retaliate to show what big tough guys
they are and you can tell they don't
actually
know anything about stoicism and they'll
also project they'll you know if you
criticize them they'll be like why are
you getting angry with me bro and you'd
be like
what a mind reader you must be so that
you can actually like read in youtube
comments uh the fact of my psychology
amazing i mean you you should be a
psychotherapist right
obviously it's it's false
um but there are a lot of these uh broix
out there
and um there's also a lot of people who
aren't really they're interested in like
little bits and pieces of stoicism
little life hacks and you know um little
little things that they can turn into
images or tattoos or stuff because they
they think that um you know virtus means
manliness and all that and you know if
you dig into their psyches or even just
observe them for a while you can tell
there's something wrong
something deeply wrong in them
um
and you don't have to you know what are
your duties towards them you don't have
to like get them out of their thing they
got themselves into their thing it's up
to them to get themselves out but
you can certainly tell them that they've
got things wrong and
you know maybe move on from there now
the anger thing so the stoics
think that anger is always bad right as
an emotion
they're famously opposed to the
aristotelians who say that no sometimes
anger can actually serve a good purpose
what often gets left out by the platonus
too i mean think about republic book
book four
thumos the part of us that gets angry
uh is is something that we need within
us so we've got you know the stoics and
the platonus and aristotelians and by
the way the epicureans too
distinguish between
a kind of natural anger which we we
should feel uh an act on and then
unnatural anger which is being driven by
vain or empty uh opinions cano uh uh
right
and
um so the stoics are kind of at an
extreme
there's others that are at that extreme
as well some christian authors later on
like john cassian for example uh who's
quite influenced by the stoics by the
way um
so the question is you know
anger is it okay or not
and even the groups that say yes are
like you gotta be really really really
careful with anger and don't mix it up
with courage because it's not the same
thing aristotle actually
in his his nick mccann ethics
book three discussion of courage where
he talks about things that are kind of
like courage but not really courage he
explicitly talks about thumos
and interestingly it's the thumbos of a
mother
animal who is trying to defend her young
he says that's not the same thing as
courage but we could think about
that as well so courage and anger there
may be some overlaps depending on whose
virtue ethics you are looking at for the
stoics they're pretty opposed and and
cicero follows the stoics on this cicero
also thinks that anger
can't be
recuperated can't be
can't be given a good function right
but you know that's something where we
might differ i would also mention that
like a rational emotive behavior therapy
which much more than cognitive behavior
therapy is explicitly connected to
stoicism albert ellis red epictetus
rational emotive behavior therapy
recognizes a
proper limited rational use of
anger or response of anger right
so maybe the stoics are wrong on this
this is something that's kind of uh an
open question among
modern stoics where where the ancient
stoics were is very clear though so
yeah
all right we got about another nine
minutes any other questions about
courage
or socialism i i did skip over somebody
had asked a question here it is colin
can we get a video on cynicism
you've already got videos on cynicism
use google
right i i have done videos on cynicism
um
the very first thing that you should be
doing instead of asking me
is using your search engine
and uh you'll find uh quite a few
so
all right any other uh
uh oh here we go uh send quitum i think
of anger is something actually being
helpful by being always there as
something to be careful about and even
supporting virtues by requiring
perseverance and courage and so forth
yeah i mean if anger is going to be
helpful it's going to be in very
restricted ways it's going to have to be
trained you're going to have to know
what you're doing with it it's not raw
material that you could use
um i don't think like you know anger is
a reminder to not slip and being
virtuous
i mean
if if it's anger directed at your own
screwing up which john cassian talks
about as the only legitimate use of
anger yeah okay maybe maybe so but
that's not the way most people
use anger they anger is very seductive
it's very easy
to um
slip into the idea and the stoics and
aristotle i love what they they have to
contribute when we bring them together
on this
anger is seductive it makes us think
that
just this once
are getting angry and our use of anger
it's not going to get out of control and
it's it's going to it's going to work
and you know
and that's part of what you know seneca
talks about this in his book on anger
right anger has all these little things
that it uses you got to act right now
right we can't wait uh because you know
we're going to lose the opportunity and
seneca says see this is how anger messes
you up so
yeah
um
quantum non-unhinged anger is more like
a tool which gives you the energy to
change undesirable circumstances
so many people go wrong by thinking that
because they think that their anger is
not unhinged anger when it is unhinged
anger should always be suspicious of
your own anger repressing anger is super
unhealthy in my opinion nobody's talking
about repressing uh your anger
you actually allow yourself if you're a
stoic
you actually do feel your emotions you
don't repress your emotions nobody said
that what you do is you don't act on
your emotions which is not the same
thing as repressing emotions
and then you start looking at things
you're like how did i get so screwed up
that this thing over here
made me angry so
um mark says i'm i'm taking it that the
next session will be on temperance yeah
we're going to wrap up uh so you know
session five will be on the verge of
temperance the other
uh uh one of the four cardinal virtues
and uh then we're gonna see where we're
going to go after that i mean there's so
many other basic stoic ideas that people
um could use you know going back to the
stomach text and seeing what they
actually
have to say like you know what what is
this stuff about the indifference you
know
preferred and rejected what the hell is
that right and you notice that's
important for for from a stoic
perspective for
um
having courage it's knowledge in part
about what's what's really good and
what's bad and what just appears so
and you know is relatively good and
relatively bad so you know we'll talk
about things like that but yeah
definitely next time is going to be
temperance
[Music]
mark says there's a difference between
your temper as a faculty and the habit
of how that temper functions so to speak
losing your temper
yeah i mean we
you know this is a good thing to close
on we are complicated things you know
um
a lot of people want to have over
simplistic what we could call
anthropologies and psychologies that is
uh philosophical understandings of you
know what human nature is and how how
our minds work right and
we are just a complicated hot mess by
the time that we come to start taking an
interest in something like stoicism
we're already screwed up in all sorts of
ways that are going to take years and
years and years to you know sort of
figure out and unravel and it's
sometimes kind of discouraging because
and this is where like perseverance
could be important right because it's
like the proverbial peeling and onion
you're like oh i'm dealing with this
this issue that i've got and you peel it
away and you're like
damn it there's another one underneath
here well maybe if i peel this one oh
darn it there's another one right very
often um
you know we should we should think of
the stoic path not as like we're gonna
like make a nice steady ascent to become
stoic sages but more like you know ups
and downs and um
it's possible to make progress over time
even if it if it is ups and downs i mean
i can tell you that it's not just from
stoicism again aristotelianism has
played a role platonism
i'm a much happier
person with a much better control over
my temper now than i was five years ago
let alone 10 years ago and all of that
marx says calling me out here greg well
i mean this is a shoe fit wears it kind
of thing right we're all kind of in
process
and this is why
life hacks are not going to get you what
you want you know when it comes to
stoicism or just memorizing quotes
stoicism is a complex coherent set of
ideas that you have to put into practice
and you learn on the way
of doing so and it's often helpful
to do so um
not only you know with other people who
can like be accountability buddies and
call you on stuff
um but also maybe with with you know
coaches or mentors which you got to be
careful of because some of them are
frauds right
um send quitting learning to be a stoic
is unlearning years of how not to be one
yeah that's a great way to put it there
that's that's that's really good there's
um not just the learning right
and and forming habits it's also
figuring out
how we're screwed up how we're vicious
and
bit by bit unraveling that right
um
quantum just trying to add i get your
answer maybe my lacking vocabulary
caused a misunderstanding i was more
aiming at what freud said about symptoms
that every symptom has a function
why do you assume freud's got it right i
mean maybe freud is actually wrong about
that a lot of people would would say
that um
you know it's uh
it's kind of a canard that that we see a
lot that stoicism involves repressing
emotions and this is a good place to end
you know the broacism stuff is about
that
don't give in to pain man you know uh no
you you know feel your pain and figure
out what's going on with that you know
um
all right so this is a good place to end
it's almost at the top of the hour
uh we're gonna i'm gonna get some lunch
and then my wife and i are going to
a
matinee performance a little little
treat during the day so glad all of you
could uh join me for this
and uh we'll we'll do another one in
about two weeks on temperance as mark
was asking about
um and you know we'll we'll keep on
rolling with these they probably are
going to continue to be on youtube live
but i have been exploring a really cool
platform called light hall that i did a
workshop on
last week and i might switch these over
to that because that's got a lot more
capabilities to like you know provide
quizzes and or polls and
documents and stuff like that so anyway
we'll see
mark gave you my reason i owe calendar
if you if you look at my stuff on like
facebook or twitter i'm always
telling you in advance when this stuff
is going to happen so all right i'll see
all of you and have a great rest of the
day wherever you happen to be